[Davion] Bad luck to nurse a bottle alone.
-Then come make my fortunes better.
-There's only one glass.
Cheers.
[Mirana] I met her when I was 13.
For ten years, everything was perfect.
Selemene protected me.
Fixed broken things.
Until I failed her.
But looking into those pools,
seeing the madness, the atrocities…
I was back in that cave.
Walking towards the darkness.
If I were still the Princess of the Moon…
This violence?
It's not who we are.
[Davion] We don't always know
who we really are.
Maybe this guy isn't the devil
your stories make him out to be.
Maybe he really does just want
to make everything how it was.
Afraid of what happens if he can't.
Maybe I'm just a scared little girl
trying to run home.
You? No.
You took down an eldwyrm.
All I did was survive.
Making you one of the few people
who ever has.
You might actually make
a good Dragon Knight.
And I've seen you in, what,
five outfits now?
Maybe you'd make a good princess.
You'll do the right thing.
Even if you're afraid. You always do.
Are you scared?
Davion the Dragon Knight
isn't afraid of anything.
I'm terrified.
[ominous music]